diop monde ces exclusions se retrouve
aujourd'hui en compagnie de janis et
ouais alors jean-pierre comment tu te
fais aujourd'hui pour attaquer l'ours
d'or
très bien je pense qu'on va [ __ ] du
gros alors c'est parti
on va aller à un endroit où il ya de la
neige comme le disait tout à l'heure
donc en passant par le ton un peu fou
voilà à jeter doublet seulement tu vas
me laisser à trois premiers alors red
dead redemption vont parler de jeu bon
moi je me connais absolument pas toi
apparemment tu l'as bien qu'ils puissent
que tes nouvelles
je suis levé le dc c'est quoi ça c'est
beaucoup
hôpital non se voit beaucoup tué mais à
la fin c'est que tu peux conduire des
zèbres et tous genres c'est un truc de
fou
genre tu peux conduire d'un bon gros des
bisons et tout ce sont tous des [ __ ]
ce salaire à ses galeries choix
l'entraîneur
on connaît en août voilà la question à
faire dans cette petite vidéo on va
chasser m je ne te laisserai pas bien
parti et chocolat d'opel en fait on a
décidé pourquoi pas de faire une petite
vidéo pour changer un peu sur la dead
redemption en attendant que je sais que
call of xbox quoi jouer en hd pvr et à
et on a décidé d'aller chasser l'ours
donc moi je connais pas du tout mais
apparemment c'est un endroit où il y
aura de la neige menace par j'embrasse
ultime come on arrive dans les périodes
de deux c'est mieux
enfin on s'est dit pourquoi ne pas
rester un peu d'ambiance du père noël
créé par coca cola en 1720 activement
aura [ __ ] c'est galère de chanter
allez voir je saute enfin ici x fait
partie donc les rives du jour on doit
tuer un ours à mains nues pas droit aux
armes et non le but est donc au couteau
a comme ça c'est parti pour scalper un
peu à peaux de bison ouais on commence à
voir la neige la neige il ya de la neige
donne à ces marées à samoëns en perles
de pâques a fait tuer par contre il
faudra sortir il faudra sortir de
chevaux pour que pourquoi elle conduit
sa mère est de nuire à paraître chez
manitou a tendance à attendre de ce
monde je vais aller découvrir la petite
bombe turquie joueurs alors regardez ça
un des quatre chevaux épique dû attendre
au plus tard mais qu on était là on met
qui les lie la résille as tu attaques
on attendait où j'aime bien là je le
suis mais je suis attendu à la ils
suivent je dois pas de moyens ainsi
germaine claude monet au
devient douce du travail c'est parti oui
vas-y diversion bien bien trop et on
peut le dire des français comme il faut
pourquoi y'a d'la joie après avoir
découvert j'ai ramassé en d4 je vais
vous dire quoi
make a scene un magnifique clint
eastwood et tu ne me vois pas ridicule
allez je vais le battre
j'ai appelé prélude à de bien oui mais
attention c'est interdit pour les
adultes et les gens bien c'est pas qu'il
faut tuer de lens mais très salée à un
partout hier mais je cours après mon âme
et vous alors pouvoir en direct tu fais
deux fois sa taille tu sais même pas
pourquoi tu remontes de suite
ouais on a été annoncée à 0 dans le
prend un contre un regarde je prends un
crochet du boyard la up
on le sent un peu de la bonne viande
mais le pire c'est qu'en solo tu as tu
peux les deux pc est tous vraiment c'est
vrai oui c'est dommage car améliorateur
attentes autant on peut les attendre
c'est quoi ça récolter de la sauge
hockey du colibri voilà tu as j'appelle
un cheval je t'ai fait tomber au bas
j'ai un peu des deux chauffards au
[ __ ] mais clairement des santons
cheval attention touch hd le tuer un
cheval au jeu les nuages balle [ __ ]
non mais attends avec faut que je
reprenne mon cheval est rien mais un
crochet du droit dont deux secondes je
le suis là [ __ ] il ya deux jours ça
c'est là que le royal il va se faire
tuer
importée à une chanteuse alors annoncé
pourquoi j'aime bien tu vas le cheval
est unique et j'en excellent c'est aussi
le véhicule penser qu'il y à t'il
demande pourquoi on a cédé vers dax en
mars et parce que john a mais qui est un
sanglier mais c'est trop la honte
les mecs bon pourquoi il peut il veut pu
tâter mon couteau barre si je crois
avoir marqué je me suis qu'il peut plus
fonctionner je crois que ce couteau
s'est transformé en bateau tu t y à
l'ours est bien lancé des fonds sert
enfin je veux dire annonce dans une
forêt est quand même assez oh [ __ ]
mais il ya un jeu pas un objet terrestre
identifie qui passait là bas mais on
était noir a été bon voilà c'est
peut-être mal était fait tellement
d'années maintenant qu'il savait qu'un
sanglier à démonter en synthèse vénère
et en fait ce n'est pas en âne c'est une
mule 2e défie ce n'est que quelques
chances c'est surprenant
petite anecdote
edmond mulet la mule est un peu plus
petit a raconté un petit temps mais les
gars derrière combat de titans tu
mettras la musique de rue que remontage
effet le moment mais compétiteur tu mets
la musique de rue que montage minuad ex
moi c'était pas du film
alors voilà donc c'était un
petit amphibien lancera ce thème en
effet c'était vraiment m
ici au plus on aurait pu mettre
commentaire mais c'est une super tu
pourras même le faire au montage certain
fc cacher son âge tu te diriges bien la
rivière et la bourse attend elle est
allée on refaire un petit deuxième
combat de titans à tintin je la tire et
en vidéo [ __ ] attention mais qu il ya
trois ans 3 ans et un sanglier ça ne
rigole plus est ce qu'il est ce qu'il
faut faire
forcément la ligue mais le style de
l'ours
alors là c'est les 3 au 6 mai non mais
que j'ai trois ours avait 3 c'est pas ça
c'est magnifique
alors qu'hier je crois que c'est une
superbe transversale sur le côté gauche
au millimètre non c'est un mec bien mal
leur vient vers moi jean-pierre se
trouve je vais voir toi attend j'appelle
un peu mon nom
alors y'a personne alors tu es prêt à
laisser partir un bp on a ce film on met
un v2 et j'avoue une la montagne qui
m'amène est homérique mais qui me
convient josh la gelée balade comme des
zombies en bouteille et j'ai peut-être
fait un peu trop le propaq histoire est
cependant c'est toi qui disparaissent
obama va écouter les gens j'espère que
ces petits délits avec un jean pierre
vous aura détendue et festive que vous
serez un peu moins tendu un peu moins
que la ficelle du string alors je ne
fais pas tendu allez un peu de temps de
l'afssa tu vas pas dire il ya une petite
tour ce qui a buggé à une bonne note - 2
- 3 et le petit augustin voile arraché
comme la cua de filles dans le 4e jeu
les pousse également à tous un fou ce
qu'ils acceptent il ne vous aura plu les
gens je vous dis à bientôt on se
retrouve bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
et qu'à tout le monde mais by des mois
je vous fais le gros bisous et accouche